t
une hausse dans l'affluence de
leur réservation. Pour certains,
c'est du jamais vu depuis le
début de la pandémie et bien
sûre, le Canadien de Montréal
y est pour quelque chose.
- L'enthousiasme pour la coupe
réanime le centre-ville
de Montréal.
Ce kiosque de restauration
rapide prolonge ses heures
d'ouverture les soirs de match.
- Tout le monde veut
de la nourriture, tout le monde
est amical, puis ça passe vite.
On aime ça.
- Avec la série finale,
c'est la folie.
- L'affluence dans cet hôtel
du centre-ville est à son plus
haut.
- On sera complets nous,
ce vendredi, pour le premier
match à domicile.
Il n'a pas atteint la capacité
pré-COVID, loin de là, environ
moitié capacité, quelques
centaines de chambres.
- Toutes ces chambres-là seront
vendues, ce qui est quand même
une première depuis 14-15 mois.
- C'est un moment absolument
magique.
- Il remarque lui aussi une
hausse de réservations dernière
minute pour venir vivre
l'effervescence au centre-ville
de Montréal en majorité des gens
de régions au Québec.
- Même des gens du Lac-Saint-
Jean quand même qui conduisent
aller-retour, dorment une seule
nuit, puis ça nous aide.
Le carnet se remplir plus.
- Des billets se revendent
à des prix astronomiques
en ligne jusqu'à 35 000 dollars
pour une paire.
- On est porté à aller voir le
match dans les restaurants.
- Allez-vous regarder le match
de ma?
- C'est sûr.
Je vais regarder ça chez nous.
- Il y a un énorme impact les
soirées de match de hockey
notamment dans les salles à
manger mais aussi au niveau de
la livraison.
- Pour les gens qui veulent
assister en personne au duel,
des billets se vendent à des
prix astronomiques en ligne,
jusqu'à 35 000 $.
Si vous n'avez pas des milliers
de dollars à dépenser, il sera
possible de regarder le match
dans les parcs de Montréal.
La ville est en discussion